let's go to our next caller from the
seven-25 area code 725 go ahead
725 if maybe you're muted but we can't
hear it oh I'm sorry there you are
this is Stefan from Nevada yeah I was
curious as to how you would recommend I
prepare for college and going to college
in the fall
and those wondering what you as
professor would suggest very good okay
let's let's so here's a couple listen by
the way most of the advice is not as
somebody who is taught in college but
it's more someone who has gone to
college gone through it and then gotten
out and gone to grad school okay so a
couple different okay number one do the
reading now that is me saying it as a as
an instructor the assuming that the
professors have thought the class is out
correctly do the reading because you are
going to get way more out of it and I
know I I hated doing the reading and I
didn't always do it when I was a student
you will actually benefit from doing the
reading so do the reading that's
assigned number two think about college
not so much as a place where the focus
is learning the subject matter of the
classes although it is and you should
make every effort to do it but
understand that college is a place
primarily to do two things number one to
learn how to learn and think okay so
consider the classes an analogy for
learning how to learn and learning how
to think and number two college is where
for a lot of people depending on whether
you're living on campus or not or moving
or whatever you're actually going to
have to figure out a lot of things for
yourself that are gonna be relevant to
the real world when you get out and
start working that may be before your
parents helped you out with or you had
teachers in school who would sort of
babysit or hold your hands through at
least in larger universities for the
most part you don't show up it's your
problem and the repercussions are going
to be yours to deal with if you're not
getting the material and you don't tell
anybody you're just going to end up with
a bad grade and it's basically going to
be your responsibility and I think that
the P
whoo I don't know whether success in
college in terms of high GPA versus like
a medium GPA translates to success in
the real world but I think anecdotally
the people that do best in the real
world
Stefon are the people who in college
learn about how it applies to life in a
way that maybe before you didn't you
didn't really have exposure to so that
would be my advice okay that makes sense
all right thank you all right no problem
thought maybe there'd be a follow-up so
I would say Dave yeah have a nice day
appreciate